wir sind unterwegs von Kiev an die
polnischukrainische Grenze eine Mission
im Schutz der Nacht deren Ziel geheim
bleiben muss aus Sicherheitsgründen
Marian Lambert ist angespannt vier
ukrainische Kinder die nach Russland
verschleppt wurden sollen gleich hier
ankommen wird alles gut gehen mariam hat
eine der Mütter an die Hand genommen
slana hat ihren Sohn und ihre Tochter
vor einem Jahr zuletzt gesehen
sie waren in der Schule es war schon
Krieg als ich kam um sie abzuholen sagte
man mir man hat sie mit nach Russland
genommen wenn alles gut läuft werden sie
in 45 Minuten hier sein zusammen mit
zwei weiteren Jugendlichen die nach
Russland verschleppt
wurden in diesem Fall z.B der Mutter mit
ihren beiden Kindern sie waren in der
Schule als das passierte und sie war zu
Hause und als die Russen in die stad K
ging sie sofort zur Schule zurück um
ihre Kinder zu holen und
unglücklicherweise war die Schule leer
sie verstand dass sie die Kinder nach
Russland gebracht hatten sie wusste
nicht wo sie sind bis heute weiß sie
nicht in welcher Stadt in Russland sie
waren banges Warten dann endlich ist es
soweit sascha ist der
erste dann folgt seine Schwester
Angelina es ist ein Moment der Stille
ein Augenblick in dem keiner Worte
findet ich danke allen aufrichtig danke
dass meine Kinder gefunden wurden ich
bin sehr froh ihr auch alles ist in
Ordnung
richtig monatelang hat Marian Lambert
für diesen Moment gearbeitet mit ihrer
Organisation seit Juni dafür ein
verschleppte Kinder zurückzuholen zum
ersten Mal ist es gelungen wie genau die
Belgierin die Kinder und Jugendlichen
zurückgebracht hat muss geheim gehalten
werden um künftige Rückführungen nicht
zu gefährden doch so viel verraten sie
fast vier Tage waren die vier unterwegs
von Russland über Lettland Litauen und
Polen in die
Ukraine im Morgengrauen Ankunft in Kiev
bevor eslana mit beiden Kindern zurück
in ihre Heimatstadt kupjansk fährt
wollen sie am nächsten Tag den
kinderschutzbeauftragten Treffen vor dem
heldenenkmal versammeln sie sich noch
einmal das ist ein wichtiger Tag für uns
wir haben endlich ein Ergebnis unserer
Zusammenarbeit erzielt und vier Kinder
aus Russland zurückgebracht alle haben
unterschiedliche Geschichten aber dies
ist die Realität das ist keine
propagandausschen schleppung
ukrainischer Kinder als Rettung
präsentiert im sibirischen Novosibirsk
kommen ukrainische Kinder an die von
russischen Familien empfangen werden die
sie adoptiert
haben die Tränen in den Augen des
kleinen zweijährigen Mädchens seien wohl
Tränen des Glücks berichtet die
Reporterin Putins Kinderbeauftragte
Maria lovova Bova ist persönlich
gekommen und berichtet sie selbst habe
einen Jungen aus mariopol adoptiert es
sei wichtig die Kinder aus den Grauen
des Krieges zu
befreien eine bislang kinderlose Familie
nimmt gleich vier Kinder mit in Sibirien
sollen sie jetzt zu russischen
Staatsbürgern erzogen
werden mehr als 700.000 ukrainische
Kinder will Russland nach eigenen
Angaben seit 2014 ins Land gebracht
haben in Ferienlagern werden ältere auch
militärisch ausgebildet um dann
irgendwann gegen Ukrain zu
kämpfen Treffen im Büro des ukrainischen
Kinderbeauftragten dimitro lubinit
Marian Lambert und ihre Organisation
arbeiten eng mit der ukrainischen
Regierung zusammen
Lubin möchte wissen wie es den Kindern
geht Sascha und Angelina reden nicht
viel ein Jahr wurden sie in einem
russischen Internat in luuchansk
festgehalten manchmal wenn ich sie nach
Russland Frage werden Sie nervös und
wollen nicht darüber reden irgendetwas
stört sie
wie empfinden Sie die Tatsache dass sie
ohne Mutter
waren sie haben gesagt dass ich Ihnen
sehr gefehlt habe es gab ja keine
verbindung wie Sascha und Angelina sind
nach ukrainischen Schätzungen 19000
ukrainische Kinder und Jugendliche seit
Beginn des Krieges verschleppt worden
ein Verbrechen hinter dem System steht
meint der
Kinderbeauftragte
es ist unmöglich oder sehr schwer
erwachsene Leute umzuschulen aber mit
Kindern kann man das machen ihre
Erinnerungen löschen Ihnen sagen dass
sie immer Russen waren dass russisch
immer ihre Sprache war dass es nie eine
Ukraine
gab Mariam will mit ihrer Organisation
nicht nur Kinder retten sie will die
Weltöffentlichkeit informieren damit
Druck auf Russland ausgeübt wird
gemeinsam mit der ukrainischen Regierung
hat sie sich dafür eingesetzt dass
erstmals Opfer in Europa jetzt selbst
von ihren Erlebnissen
berichten in chmelnitzki treffen wir
Ivan und Maxim ihre Geschichte ähnelt
der von Sascha und Angelina und ist doch
ganz anders verlaufen die beiden wollen
denen die nicht reden können eine Stimme
geben im März wurden sie nach donjetk
verschleppt und zwei Monate in einem
Krankenhaus festgehalten heimlich
konnten sie ihren Schuldirektor per
Handy informieren der sie zurückbra
bchte über mehrere Landesgrenzen waren
sie tagelang in Bus und Taxi unterwegs
traurig macht Ivan der Gedanke an die
jüngeren Kinder die zurückbleiben
mussten sie waren in einem Alter in dem
sie nicht verstehen konnten was mit
ihnen passierte ich glaube sie wollten
auf jeden Fall nach Hause einige weinten
und einer bat uns seinen Großvater
anzurufen Ivan packt seine Sachen er hat
keine Angst mehr er ist entschlossen
über das Unrecht das ihm angetan wurde
zu berichten die Weltöffentlichkeit
müsse Druck auf Russland
ausüben es ist
offensichtlich ein Kind aus einem Land
zu entführen ist dasselbe als wollte man
ein Kind gefangen halten es ist nicht
richtig Schuldirektor Anton Bay hat sich
entschlossen Ivan und Maxim zu begleiten
im Morgengrauen brechen sie auf im Auto
geht es zunächst nach Polen von dort aus
werden Sie weiter fliegen in den Hag
werden sie zusammen mit sechs anderen
Jugendlichen erwartet die auch nach
Russland verschleppt
wurden